[Music]
number of years ago i was checking out
of a really beautiful hotel felt so
lucky to stay there in big sur i was
checking out of the post ranch inn
and i heard this very familiar voice say
oh
justin is that you
it sounded like george harrison i turned
around and it looked just like george
harrison
it was so surreal and it was his son
danny
and i had played george harrison a
couple years earlier in the movie walk
hard which i i never talked about on
this show
but um
uh and he said yeah you know he paid me
the nicest compliment he said we will
watch the scene and
he was very complimentary this is a
braggy story there's no way around it no
but it's still cool it was so cool and
could not have been sweeter a lot like
i imagined his father to be you know
very the coolest beetle the one maybe
the coolest person and now the coolest
offspring of a beetle yeah i mean that's
when you ask people on the show about
their legacy and stuff like what a great
legacy to leave behind like just like a
really kind compassionate
son heir to your kind compassionate uh
legacy
i choose the beatles over the rolling
stones yeah me too me too
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
uh you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
with me as always is my um
well it's my paul
my john who would you be if you were a
beatle oh wow good question i
well i just finished saying that george
here is the coolest one so i don't want
to say george but he was my favorite
well they say he's the quiet one and
you'll probably in a group of four other
people you'd be the quiet one don't you
think i think so it depends what three
other people i'm with that's true i mean
if you're with a club yeah i'm just
imagining some i have some i have a very
quiet friend named john conway who would
be the george of our group uh but john
like george was uh is very very smart
very funny george was very funny and so
the few things he would say um but then
you you know they were all funny though
i know you ever watch those old i mean
yeah the footage the hard day's night
and stuff they're funny in different
ways though like they were such scamps
and
paul was like cutesy flirty funny yeah
real scamp he was a real little speaker
he was a troublemaker trouble you
jumping on people he was like they were
all so fun loving even john john has a
reputation now i mean he became uh you
know he was more like cerebral activist
and well
slippery slope to talk about children
but uh in the beginning he even got in
on the on the mirth mm-hmm they were
mirthful they were um
yeah it was it meant so much to me that
his his son i mean just doing that day
in that movie meant so much to me to get
to uh
honor his legacy we've talked about the
movie a lot i won't talk about it more
but um just yeah it was cool to meet him
well the beatles uh went on to inspire a
very popular movie from what like two or
three years ago now yeah it's called
yesterday a movie that i have not seen
that you have seen i i that you are like
emotional about you like you like it so
much yeah i
i should see it it's actually insulting
to you now at this point that i haven't
seen it because you speak so glowingly
of it well every time we go to watch a
movie when we're together which has been
often um i it's always i think the first
or second thing i suggest we do is what
we got to see yesterday because i'm
dying to see it again
when i watched it on the plane um
i had to go to the bathroom
to like
get the tears off me i was like weeping
i was weeping it was don't want to see
it with you because
number one i i don't like watching
movies typically with people who have
already seen it i want to i like going
in fresh with people
number one number i'm not gonna ruin it
i don't know well enough to like say the
line well number two and the bigger
number
you like it so much and i know how much
you like it that i have a feeling you
would make sounds
throughout it
yeah
you would i would make like
almost sexual sounds throughout that
movie i have a friend who does that um
you know when you see a play that's like
has powerful scenes and like people and
some people in the audience like what
yeah i hate that i do too
but you would do that if we saw
yesterday together tell me i'm wrong i
wouldn't do it so you knew that i was
experiencing that i would do it because
it was like authentic of course i'm not
i'm not saying you'd perform it but i
know i haven't but but your performance
your instinct would be
oh oh my god yeah it'd be hard to watch
and and not be audible yeah
um it's so good for those of you who
haven't seen it uh it's about
it
it's like a twilight zone episode it's
like it's like a beautiful twilight zone
uh episode about a world where the
beatles don't exist this guy wakes up
this singer-songwriter wakes up uh and
he's incredible in it god i'm forgetting
his name but
he's incredible so he wakes up and the
beatles don't exist and so he just like
gets to take all the beatles songs since
he starts writing
um
and we christian i've been talking
lately about plagiarizing and
and um
people who uh plagiarize other people uh
we were not talking about it like we
thought it would be a good idea for us
to do it no that was a little misleading
that's true
recently yeah so um so we decided to i
decided to start calling christian uh
monica
padman
why because we're playing trice oh yeah
it's a plagiarizing joke uh anyway why
are we talking about yesterday the movie
yesterday and the beatles i know
why why because our guest today was a
cast member
of the movie yes lamorne morris is our
guest today and lamourne we thought we'd
talk about lamorne we thought we'd take
a different angle than new girl because
uh people may be sick of hearing about
new girl on the show or not not new girl
fans that well that's true but uh one
new girl found a show i'd never get sick
of talking about or hearing about new
girl yeah you know what's so popular
podcast you know how they do about the
office
i'm sure
angela kinsey and yeah they do they do
it um
jenna joel mchale does it with the
community yeah hey good
community um yeah so i wonder if they'll
do i'm sure they'll do a new girl
podcast at some point anyway uh until
they do uh here's here's a podcast this
is the closest thing yeah maybe today
it's happening
it's heavy on your girl but we also talk
about a lot about um lamorne's new show
which i really love uh you're gonna hear
me
gush about it um it's called woke it's
on hulu right now can't recommend it
enough and uh and yesterday if you
haven't seen it lamorne is just he's a
phenomenal actor and he's a great guy i
really missed uh talking to him and it
was great to catch up with him so
why don't we do it sure here it is uh my
catch-up with my old new girl castmate
current woke star
lamorn morris
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
oh it's good to see you oh you too man
you too
are you in so you're in austin now i am
i am in austin i miss that place so much
uh uh i'm going to send you a couple of
the white horse's grades
um there's so many oh gosh let me tell
you something justin and the social
climate that we're in right now i am not
going to a place called white no i i
why i just refused because i don't like
horses and inhumane treatment of them
that's right i forgot
you're you're um
first of all it's so good i haven't seen
you in um trying to remember how long
it's been but i guess since the last
i don't know five years
man it's been a while was this since
you've been on the show or have fun uh
yeah
yeah i i was shocked to learn recently
that jake you jake and max don't
hang out don't hang out i didn't know
that honestly that's something that we
max and myself have been wondering why
that's the case
jake
jake is completely unavailable to to
oh see he made it sound like it was just
the thing that happened between the
three you guys like it just this is how
it worked out that we just end up not
seeing each other no that's his excuse
i can show you i could show you plenty
messages where i'm like hey jake you
want to hang out and be friends
and then he's like who is this
you know or
or no dude i'll facetime him i don't
believe jake has ever answered a
facetime call from me
well the way he explained it was like
it's weird that you're just why would we
do that
uh and in a way i get it i kind of get
both sides it's like
i think i hang out with jake once but it
may have been to like talk about a pro
it may have been like ostensibly to talk
about a project and we ended up just
bullshitting and having fun but um
he also said that when you guys are
together i mean this may have something
to do with that not to make excuses for
him but like he said when you guys are
together
it becomes like holy [ __ ] it's the guys
from new girl
yes
that it just amplifies how recognizable
you all are
[Laughter]
but that's really cool though
that's not the worst is that the worst
thing
it's not the worst actually it could be
it could be pretty disastrous if all of
us are like you wouldn't be able to
eat you wouldn't be able to grab a beer
she wouldn't be able to you know that's
what he said and i imagine that is true
because as i said to him after i had
been acting for a while before i went on
new girl and that gave me being just
being on a few episodes that was like
all of a sudden i was getting recognized
by and for the most part younger people
yeah you know it's like oh my god your
paw and they wouldn't even call me my i
had this arrogance that like i had done
enough that they might maybe they know
my name you know yeah and they'd be like
they call me my character's name they'd
be like oh [ __ ] it's genslinger
and i i played kind of a he was like a
nerdy goofy guy on that show so they
kind of treat me like kenzlinger they're
like classic and
you know i'm like
thing to do
yeah yeah okay slinger
um
man that's insane that that show the one
like you know we'll do that for you oh
yeah
within a couple weeks of that first
episode and i remember doing it for like
it's funny to think about now doing it
like not certainly not begrudgingly but
kind of like
oh that might be a fun diversion i
wasn't working and i was a fan of zoey's
and i knew jake a little bit but like
you know it was like i mean had i known
now
i would have been far more eager to yeah
that's my agent's psych make sure and
then it became this thing but at the
time i don't even think it had aired yet
and uh
i just remember there being so much
excitement on you know about this new
show you were doing i remember you uh we
hadn't aired yet and i remember
us going in the editing offices
and looking at a little piece of an
episode with you i think i remember
sitting watching it and
and you just being like super chill
about it and i remember i was going like
oh
i wonder what it looks like
i don't wonder what it's going to be
well yeah well this was your first it
was your first major thing right yeah
yeah my first i mean i've done some tv
hosting before like i used to work for
bet
um and i had a video game and gadget
show
on that network then i did a bunch of
commercials prior to
all right like too many commercials i
was getting recognized from commercials
like i was on tv hey you twix dude are
you the
oh vegas dude and i was getting that a
lot i think jake actually at the
audition knew me from commercials
well i lamar i think i think my mom was
a commercial actress and i think that is
a really great
training ground um i was talking to a
friend of mine who does most of the
commercials and was kind of down on it
and and
i said i made the point to her that like
if you can be convincing and natural
when you're when you're like going on
about toothpaste how much you love this
toothpaste
that trains you for when then you have a
great
grounded script or like a really funny
script like new girl yeah it's like it
must be such a relief to get to like
sink your teeth into that 100
i remember i met bj novak
once in my life i think one time he kept
staring we were at a dinner it was a
random dinner it was this one it was one
of those things where i got invited by
some produce new girl producers it was
myself it was jeff ross
bj novak and john mayer
and john was doing comedy
and so they wanted us to sit with him
and just listen to some of his stuff and
like i mean i guess taking i don't know
i was late to the dinner so i got there
and they were just throwing jokes back
and forth and i was like what is going
on at this table
and uh and i just remember bj going
dude
i love that twix commercial you did i
was like thank you man and i was like
yeah i'm just you know trying to
graduate out of that and you know just
tv is a new thing for me and figure you
know we were having a conversation about
it he goes if you can make somebody
laugh in 30 seconds in a twix commercial
you he's like that's great man you can
do it in in tv and that for some reason
gave me more confidence you know to keep
it just right i i just was struck by how
how much chemistry you guys all had
right away it's like you had
you had known each other for a while and
you had been working together for a
while but it had only been a couple
weeks i want to say yeah
was it how quick did that happen how
quick did that gel pretty pretty quick
um
right off the bat it was like all hands
on deck thing just because my character
wasn't
written for yet it was a bit of a
replacement after the first episode
you replaced yeah that's right damon
wayne's junior
yeah after the pilot and had you seen
what he did with it did they want i mean
it was a totally different character
right yeah but i did see at the time
when he had done the pilot they didn't
obviously want he couldn't finish the pi
he couldn't finish the season
he had to go back to happy endings and
so they had asked
all the actors reading for the new
character to just watch because actually
originally they wanted us to they were
thinking about replacing coach
that character thinking about redoing
the pilot and so they had asked us to
watch the pilot and i was one of the
only people who had really known
what was happening because i had
come close to getting the part
originally i had four auditions already
prior to it oh wow um
for in fact they offered me the part um
they offered me the part
but the problem was i had just accepted
an offer two hours prior
uh
cbs and i had to leave the test for new
girl because i got an offer in so i
didn't go and do the test lamorne was
that like an uncharacteristically busy
successful pilot season for you or had
other pilot seasons been had you been
getting close like that other years
that was my only pilot season oh no [ __ ]
yeah and it was a back and forth between
cbs and fox and it was pretty cool just
because i you know it was a okay so the
cbs show was a show called the
assistance with uh tj miller and heather
locklear and david henry sarah wright
and jason jones it was a fun show fun
cast a multi-cam hybrid show but then i
remember having the first audition and
tanking it
but it wasn't my fault the casting
assistant was reading with me
thought she would go off script
and dropped lines oh boy and was
dropping so many lines and i like to
improvise so i was kind of
trying to vibe with her but then she
would go back and i was like where is
she in the script like it's so far off
and so i didn't get that originally they
said they passed on me so i went to my
agent at the time and said
i need to go back in and i'll demand
that she's not reading with me or at
least that she reads the paper and
they're like it kind of give me that
like who who do you think you are kind
of thing and i was like well it's my
career and so that's what i did i went
back in and she and and they said they
said okay great uh you can come back in
and read but this time it's a producer
session i'm surprised the casting
director let her or them was it a
let them do that but
well at the time it was just the
assistant because no one knew who i was
so you know you you probably forget
these days when you don't actually sit
down with the producers on the first go
around or the cast i don't know yeah i
know but but at least the casting
director who that's that's a lot of
liberty for a casting i mean this is
going to be very inside baseball uh
but that's i'm surprised that's
surprising to me yeah so i went back in
and the producers were there and they
said and they stopped me again while i
was reading
and then i thought
[ __ ] i'm just a really bad actor and
then they go hey we hear you're testing
for new girl tomorrow
it's like yeah yeah and they go can we
ask you to tank that audition
i was like wait what like uh make me an
offer and then we'll talk you're like
bring in that casting assistant yeah
have her have her read with me yeah it's
the new girl
man yeah exactly oh my god and so
i went to the test for new girl because
that was the show i really wanted was
new girl
um and so i went to the test and then
this is a quick sidebar during that time
i didn't know anything about tv or the
business or
i don't know what the first position was
her second position was so i was
clueless and
a buddy of mine he had just finished the
show chad boseman
so chadwick boseman came by my buddy's
apartment while helping me read lines
and and started breaking down like what
the pros and cons
of each
thing would be wow and he's like the one
you want to do is the one you want to go
for however
pilot seasons don't happen like this
this is like you take the offer
and so
yeah i went anyway i took it and then
while i was at the audition
right before i went in you know you
signed the contract or whatever
i get a call from my agent like don't
sign the contract cbs just made you an
offer and for more money and you know so
that's what that's what ended up
happening and then after i signed the
contract then fox comes back and says
hey can we make you an offer and it was
too late it must have been a struggle i
mean that's a good struggle to have but
it must have been a weird moment in your
life very weird i remember
sitting in the courtyard area at fox
on the phone and i was with a friend of
mine who was helping me read lines and i
was so giddy and so excited and then her
demeanor just changes slightly
and i turn around it's liz merriweather
and jake kasden
you know walking past me like hey man
they're the creators of new growth yeah
and they just yeah
it didn't uh not only they were very
happy with me in that moment um
but you know ultimately ended up working
out i mean i have 15 auditions for new
girl
wow well
obviously yeah it worked out and then um
i remember that they've roles certainly
you and jake's roles weren't nearly as
defined um as they later came to be i
remember thinking that about you in fact
like
i remember thinking god this guy's so
much
funnier than what he's being given in a
way like he you did these incredible
impressions you were so quick you
were just more versatile than i and it's
through nobody's fault certainly not
liz's they just didn't um
it hadn't been
with you yeah they didn't know you know
i guess
when you're developing something you're
probably sitting with these characters
for for quite a long time
and um this character was so last minute
on the fly like we don't want to replace
damon
obviously he comes back in the show and
he you know he's a very he's a big part
of our show
so they wanted to create a different
character the problem was is that we
were shooting in like two weeks
you know so i had to go through all the
business stuff you know photo shoots we
had to do our big gallery shoot
you know you know junkets whatever it
was we were doing i forget but it was a
lot of work before we even started
filming so we did get we did develop a
rapport with each other especially
because like i said i had i want to say
15 auditions or close to it for the show
so we know he's crazy you know what i
mean oh right right
if you had to like describe to people
who who winston was then
and who he was in the final season of
the show
how would you do that how would you
articulate winston in the first few
episodes
or or who he was supposed to be
well i would say he was
and and written into his character he
was a bit of a fish out of water i don't
know who these people are kind of guy
you know what i mean he i would say he
was more
observant
and weary and there are a lot of like
you know these white people type jokes
you know that they were written in there
it's like
because nick was my friend coming up but
schmidt we didn't really like each other
that much because i knew him from
college he was nick's new you know newer
friend and
didn't know zoey's character you know
didn't know hannah simone's character so
it was more so just observing and going
you know i'll be honest with you it was
one of those things where you got like
the writing was a bit more it was a bit
on the nose as far as like
ah like look at these white people man
you know one of those it's hard to
explain it but no no i yeah no i know i
i i was doing this thing with my brother
um it was a ridiculous show where we
were just watching tv basically and and
um
it was like celebrity watch party raven
simone was on it and uh
i think i heard her say like
at least twice like
it would we would christian i would do
something and then would cut to her and
she'd go ah white people you know or
something like that and and um
it's weird it's the kind of thing where
it's like funny the first time and then
it like the second and third time you're
like wait is that all you have is that
your
go-to you know um and i imagine for
somebody like you you're so
naturally funny and
on your own you have just such a rich
comedic
mind that
i don't know what does that feel well it
felt you know
to be to be fair
they're all brilliant writers so it felt
like oh yeah they wanted me to have
something to do and they were trying to
test stuff out because that stopped
quickly you know what i mean on one it
would start and then it would be like
okay that's not that's not playing very
well
because to be honest with you i didn't
even like
doing it you know what i mean because
there is more to
what we all know how to do you know what
i mean so so for to start it was a lot
of that then it was okay
let's let's figure out which career he
has and so my character bounced around
from job to job to job then it became
like oh maybe that's the bit is that he
can't keep a job and then i started
thinking like okay well
here's what i don't want to do either i
don't be the only black dude on the show
and he can't keep a job like
that's like right that's right that's
not a great look yeah i was like all
right man yeah there's a lot of kids
looking up to the show like
you know that's true and so but they did
such a great job of of like playing with
it and making it making it more of a bit
than it was like real character arc it
was more just like funny things to try
to
figure out while we
figured out the character because i
would imagine even me now trying to
write stuff i know how hard it is to
develop things and i can imagine while
in the middle of filming a a prime time
show trying to create another character
on top of it and it's a testament to
your skill
your skill set that you were able to
navigate all of those you know
experiments all those different
storylines that
never really went anywhere and then you
know you obviously ultimately settled on
something that's really special but um
but i and i it reminds me of the a
review i read of yours in
just last night uh about your new show
about woke and in the new york times
it's if you haven't read it you should
it's an incredible review and and it's
so on the nose in terms of uh
articulating what what makes you so good
in this new character you're playing
keefe on on woke um that you are
able to to navi you're able to play
befuddled and grounded in a way that's
very accessible and um
how much of that of your experience on
new girl do you think led to you
playing keefe i mean what what is that
character evolution like in in your mind
a lot a great deal um i loved playing
winston because
you know there were stakes but there
weren't any real stakes you know yeah
yeah he was very
i like to say playing winston was like
being in a sketch comedy group because
each each scene he had a different trait
there was something so weird about him
every episode i'd read the table read
and i would go oh so now he
he now he he gets boners randomly and
he's like
yeah well that was written
to be fair i mean that was because you
were talking a lot about that in your
own personal yeah because it happens all
the time yeah you know what i mean like
and that's and that's on me that's on me
yeah that was something that you were
very passionate about at the time
bringing awareness to yes random boners
happening yeah yeah i mean when i say
they happen all the time dude like i'd
be legit like all the time what are you
doing what are you doing
why are you doing that bro
what happened what is that it's my boner
are you kidding no that's my room the
morning just stood up oh it's a cup oh
jesus
i was like
well done
that's impressive
i wish this weren't a podcast now
uh that's class that's by the way that's
classic winston
um
but i see i like the the great thing
about you playing keefe and and i really
want to talk about whoa because it's so
let me first ask you are you sick of
talking about it because i know you're
doing a lot of press for it right now no
no you know not really i i'm it's new to
me still to be honest with you i haven't
even sat down to
to
fully just watch it by myself you know
it's great it's i'm excited for that to
happen but but you play a cartoonist who
is
certainly your work is not at all
controversial it's not
uh at all racially based people like it
but it's for the most part benign yeah
in terms of like any sort of social
justice causes
and this this event happens to you
a friend of mine was on the show james
blake and the same exact thing happened
to him
uh he was tackled by police they had the
wrong guy
um there was no proper apology or
explanation um and this causes your
character to
really wake up i mean it's kind of like
it's kind of like a twilight zone
episode where you then start noticing
all of these things that it's so good
it's so well done you're great in it um
but i would imagine doing press about
something like this
is tricky it's very tricky because
you know on one hand that's a lot of
people's stories especially i would say
in my personal life a lot of black men
have dealt with the police in a way that
a lot of white men haven't
the tones are different when you're
approached by a cop and that's not all
the time i've i've broken the law like
i've been full on speeding and switching
lanes and doing all kinds of stuff and
the cop pulls me over it is like he's
like all right man just be safe
you know and i'm like was that
like was that because you he recognized
you on the show i don't think so i don't
think so i just think it was like
it wasn't like i was putting anyone's
life in danger it was more so yeah like
okay we're it's no one's out like no
one's on the road i get it but like just
chill out slow down
so you know but it could have gone it
you know
anyway we've seen it go sideways for a
lot of people um and then where you grew
up lemon i mean you grew up outside
chicago right was it what was that well
i grew up in chicago and then when i was
in high school i moved to the west burbs
which was totally different from the
south side of chicago oh wow so on the
south side of chicago yeah you get like
when you were a kid playing basketball
in an alley somewhere and police roll by
flash their lights and go boop and just
keep it moving and we're like but we're
like eight years old playing basketball
keep it moving where what are you like
you know we are you know we're in the
middle of yeah this is where we this is
my house like that's my friend's house
so that's something you so you just got
used to that that was just like you
didn't
really
and then when you see a more mixed then
did you move to a more like white yeah a
more yeah more white neighborhood um and
then you don't see any issues you know
police are actually really friendly you
know so it's fascinating as a kid then
lamorne uh do you look back at
how do you process that time earlier
that when you were a kid it's like wait
a minute did you immediately put it
together that like oh it's because i'm
black it's because of this no when
you're a kid you just
this is and i don't want to piss anybody
off and i'm not trying to ruffle any
feathers with police officers or you
know
you know people with officers in their
family or friends that's not that's
that's not what i'm trying to say but as
a kid
we only knew the police to be
not for us necessarily yeah yeah i don't
think that's a controversial that's your
experience i mean you're just stating
that's all i knew that's all you know
you know um
so when you obviously when you get older
you start to understand
you know oh that's not the case maybe it
just feels that way because of certain
circumstances in your neighborhood where
you come from but we're taught that you
know we're taught like when you see the
police you know you know keep your head
down walk away
you know do those types of things some
some kids just straight up run
you know what i mean like i remember we
would walk to school from my house we
walked to school which was probably like
half a mile away and if you see the
police going like some kids and i'm
talking
like we're legit in fifth grade sixth
grade and some of my buddies are idiots
and just bolt running and i'm like
why are you running you don't even
you're not doing anything illegal like i
know why they're running but i for me
it's more so like just keep your head
down and act like you don't see him and
just keep walking to school
but those other kids that they're like
yo please let's go
and then as you get older you're like oh
they're just mimicking what they see
probably from their like older brothers
or uncles or something like that of
course and yeah you know but no i was
never harassed by the police as a kid
that was just the mindset that we had
you know what i mean life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
so when you're doing that scene that's
seen in the the pilot of woke where
you're like your roommate who's great
clovis yeah clothes yeah
oh man tea something yeah
team
he's so good he's so good um
and he's like okay you're finally
starting to
to see you know you're starting to like
understand did you ever have that moment
like like your character does in the
pilot where it's like holy [ __ ] well i
did when i was about 18 or 19. i
remember doing this um
industrial video you ever you know those
videos where you're like yeah yeah i had
to do quite a few of those when i first
started actually for companies companies
will hire you and say like this is how a
uh our sprockets work yeah this is
sexually harass someone in the workplace
yeah that's a better example yeah
there's a lot of those i've done a few
of those
don't put your hand on jean's butt it's
like oh okay yeah
you play the role of gene yeah uh yeah
yeah nice but um yeah
but i remember having we should get to
that you were a butt model for a while i
didn't want to get to that yeah i do i
got a pretty sick uh circumference yeah
people know that but we need to talk
about it uh well so you're doing an
industrial yeah and it's for eating
healthy for kids like eat smart type of
thing and so i remember we're in a band
and i play the leader of this band and
we're singing these cheesy songs to help
kids understand the benefits of eating
healthy or something like that i was
like i was like 18. i'm the only black
one in the on the thing and the rest of
the bad mates are white and they're like
just kind of mean mugging looking cool
they're in a band kids on the drums like
he's in a band or whatever and i
remember this one take in particular i
was you know they're mean mugging some
kind of me mugging too like you know
it's my first gig one of my first gigs
and the director she's like hey lamar
smile more and so i'm like oh okay cool
so i'm like
he's gonna smile i'm like
she's like smiling let's see those teeth
smile
smile
and now she's yelling at me
she's like
by the way that's such a funny thing to
be yelled at yes smile yes that's insane
and i thought to myself and i was like
as it was happening
i look around me and i'm starting to
like legit get teary-eyed i'm sure there
are outtakes if they're somewhere of me
kind of going like okay looking confused
they say cut i get up that's about 50
people i'm the only black one there and
i get up and i walk away to the dressing
room and i instantly burst into tears
and i'm like
one did i just screw this thing up two
i've never heard why are they screaming
at me to see my teeth so much like why
is it so important that that that
happens and i didn't it didn't register
with me until i was talking to like this
old head this og dude at church about it
and he goes throughout our history
black people get called threatening if
they're not smiling and you're more
non-threatening when you smile and a lot
of old movies you see when you know
black guys are always smiling oh sure
just you know and
and i didn't realize that i didn't
realize that was a thing and i also
didn't realize that post that
when i would when i walked down the
street or i would you know be on
elevator or you'd see someone at school
you know when they would walk if a white
person walks by
you smile
you know to show them that hey i'm i'm
i'm cool i'm cool like you know and i
don't even realize i'm doing it you know
yeah yeah yeah until you realize you're
doing it and that's why a lot of times
when we see these things and we see
these things in the media we see things
on tv
you know
regardless of the circumstance if
someone gets shot in the back or
something like that they'll say well
you know he had a criminal record
and it's like a lot of people have a
criminal record and haven't been shot in
the back and i was like that's her go to
because he had committed a crime before
he deserved to get shot in the back so
there's all those justifications that i
get when i post stuff online for example
people comment people dm me
and oh yeah yeah i'm like it's crazy
i've read some of those lamar and it's
it's
people are so triggered so outraged by
the slightest suggestion that things
need to change yeah well how do you keep
from letting your anger spill on to the
your instagram account and and
responding in such a way that is
measured and or not responding at all
like how how do you handle that it's one
of those things where i heard stephen a
smith you know stephen a smith yeah
like one of my favorites i bet you do an
impression i i used to i don't know if i
just do it
all right he has he has okay he has this
thing where he talks about uh cancel
culture so he's like yeah he'll say
stuff like uh he was like
i'm so sick and tired of people being
canceled all the time how come okay okay
okay anyway that's my bad impression
okay okay okay
and then he'll say so he'll say he said
something about he goes why are we
canceling people for saying things that
maybe that they're misinformed on or or
or it's ignorance coming from their part
why don't we try counseling people let's
try let's try out something called
council culture so i like that if
someone on your timeline says something
crazy to you
maybe they're trolling but maybe they're
genuinely curious or genuinely missing
and misinformed
yeah you know where they come from their
household maybe they're being taught a
completely different thing or maybe
they're seeing a completely different
thing in their neighborhood in their
tiny area where they live in or the city
that they come from so you never know so
instead of barking back going yeah yeah
like an idiot you don't know what are
you talking about get off my page i'll
say why do you feel that way and here's
why i feel the way i feel because the
facts say this because i am black i've
witnessed it i've seen it i've gone
through it
so you explain things that way and then
you before you know it you're developing
an actual dialogue with someone as
opposed to ridiculing and i would love
for people to see for to react the same
way
on the opposite end you know if i miss
you yeah you know exactly tell fill me
in like let's talk about it and i
thought it was so interesting that you
had this revelation when you were
being
screamed at to smile that was behavior
that you and that that you were uh
participating in this behavior that is
so ingrained
that like even you you know
that's what's great about woke it's
great about the show is that you've been
living in a black body you've been
living in this body for so long and yet
there are things that are just occurring
to you absolutely that's one of the
reasons why i gravitated towards the
show
when i read the script originally was
because it mirrored my life in so many
ways you know talking about politics and
having opinions on things was not
my bag at all yeah i just i just wanted
to act watch basketball play basketball
with friends
talk to girls go home like that was like
my whole life and uh
i just remember reading the script going
man like this guy
is exactly like me sometimes people are
just in tune to it sometimes it's you
know
their environment the family that they
have around them maybe teaches them an
early age for us you know for a lot of
folks it's just
just get along just
live a normal life get along keep your
head down
and that's one thing that this when i
read the script i was trying to
connect with on a more personal basis
well it feels that way it's such um
again i'm not gonna like go on about how
good you are but but there are moments
where it feels
i just heard this great marlon brando
quote and i hope i don't butcher it but
he says
it's about theater acting versus film
acting and he says uh theater acting is
when uh is when you show people uh how
you're feeling and and this terrible
impression
and film acting is when you just feel it
in terms of just feeling it that moment
where you get arrested you get thrown
down and
and it's all shot in a really beautiful
way it's shot in this kind of slow-mo
and you see your friend
trying to protect you your your white
friend and he's poking literally poking
at the cops and uh and you're it you
kind of
there's there's a there's such a
palpable sense of being demoralized and
being um belittled being being made to
feel less than in that moment that it
was it's such a beautiful
i'm telling you lamar like i i think
you're going to get nominated for this
that's what it's about
but um in that moment i wasn't thinking
at all about how it was making me feel i
just thought he's getting nominated
it's really i could tell that you had
knew what that was like and you were
conveying it so beautifully um so i'm
really excited to mention thank you dude
that means that means a lot man i
remember shooting this thing and we had
so many
just on the more more on the surface
level
so many hiccups in vancouver filming
you know what i mean that
it wasn't shot in san francisco no we
shot a lot of second unit stuff in san
francisco but um but most of the most of
the heavy lifting was done in vancouver
um okay fantastic beautifully shot i
mean it
like we we got our crew was great you
know and but the weather was one of the
this was the thing the weather was the
thing you know you got to shoot a seat
on the ground with your you know
you are you being cuffed and your face
is on the ground but what they don't
know is that it was previously snowing
and we've had to clear out some space
for you to lay on that cold
t-shirt so all you were marlon brando
thinking was like holy [ __ ] this is cool
yeah
okay well i got a trip
i was feeling cold in this moment
okay
i really felt it yeah
being in that moment there in particular
it definitely comes from a place of one
sadness for the people who have gone
through it but to you know just
remembering the times that i had gone
through it through similar scenarios you
know and
and it helped with the having the extras
in the background with their phones out
i genuinely for a split second felt like
man i'm getting beat up you had
mentioned chadwick boseman earlier and i
know you guys were friends was he able
to see it did you were you able to talk
to him about this i would imagine it's
something that he probably would have
been very proud of well i told him about
when i got it you know and when i was
going to the process of of getting it
he'd never seen it
unfortunately it's one of those things
where he was kind of like uh
like a distant big brother you know and
a mentor where he would coach me on
certain things i got auditions i
auditioned for selma for example and you
know he came by the house and coached me
like like aggressively coached me on it
like he like the guy is intense like i'm
talking an intense actor and um
and like and i like to do bits and i
like to joke around and i was kind of
doing a bit out of a scene and he
stopped me and goes
hey brother in this film it's an hour
and a half two hours long
and the story of the march on selma was
a significant story in american history
um i don't think they'll have room for
jokes in this thing
i was like oh okay like that's good
advice yeah that makes sense you're
right uh i didn't get the part obviously
but uh but it was not for lack of yeah
mr boseman's health yeah so he
yeah that's just how he's always been
you know he helped me get a roommate
when i was broke in l.a he's always kind
of
in the distance
how do you know him um a good friend of
mine ramses him in as another actor
who's like my brother ramses is like my
best friend in the world like he's
you know we've been friends since we
were 18 19 i want to say did our first
film together anyway so him and i we
moved to new york together came to l.a
roughly around the same time
and him and ramses were developing a
movie together so chad is a writer chad
wrote um a play called deep azure
and
ramses and chad and yeah ramses chad and
uh
chad's partner were trying to
develop it into a
a film
and so and ramses and i were were
friends so chad would always be around
and he was going through his regular
acting motions as we all do and oh i got
an audition for this audition for that
and so we just became like a little crew
in new york and then in la a little bit
um
and then obviously you know over time
you all start everyone starts to develop
their own worlds you know ramses lives
over here now he's in dominican republic
and chad's you know back and forth to
new york or wherever he is and i'm in
you know chicago and la
and then we just keep in touch through
through text that was it you know what i
mean last time i saw him was that
all-star in chicago
um
you know that was that was difficult
just because of
you know
because i'll start what
nba nba all-star oh yeah that was
difficult because eric gordon should
have won that dunk contest and
chad was a part of the judging crew and
they screwed that up d-wade d-wade
weldy wade's fault anyway uh
i don't remember that what was that i i
don't i
tried to see all those times yeah it was
it was one of those it was that dunk
contest where they were going back and
forth they kept getting 50 50 50 scores
and it was like at this point the
chad text me and said the plan was for
them to just hold up
you know a name
and then
they had put scores up and one person
didn't put the right score
yeah
and it made it so derrick jones jr won
as opposed to eric gordon winning
those those dunks have gotten so it's
like i remember being a kid and like
even when like dee brown did the like
close you know no look duck i remember
thinking like what more can they do you
know like
and then they started like launching
each other from their jumping off of
backs
yeah getting really creative and uh
yeah oh man but no that was not that
long ago it wasn't that long ago it was
february in chicago um oh [ __ ] yeah
and you know the crazy thing is that he
was keeping that
you know he was keeping cancer so close
to the vest that
yeah you know i didn't even know about
it you know i would see him we would see
each other at an event or something like
that and
and we had this thing going he he's he's
a very he's very competitive
you know where like he's a he's a
martial artist i forget which um
which art he studies but um he's a
martial artist so he's very like you'll
see him by himself like doing things
with his hands and like that's all the
time and so i remember
every time i see him i would like act
like i could whoop his ass
the guy is so freakishly strong that i
would do like one of these and he would
grab your wrist in such a way that it's
like man this is abuse
chad stop
chad we're in public he's like it's art
yeah this is this is art this is my
discipline
um so i saw him at a party once and i
and i and he was looking thinner and i
just remember
like going oh lose his way down he's
like i was trying a new diet he's like
but i'm stronger than i ever been and i
was like no you're not and i'm like this
and he grabbed my arm and like i was
like holy [ __ ] he's strong
god it's
i don't know if it's more tragic or more
unbelievable that he was able to do all
that while he was battling it's fat it's
unbelievable to me it's unbelievable
because let me tell you something if i
even get a headache the world will know
about it
like i am such a [ __ ]
i'm such a [ __ ]
i want all the sympathy
right you put it on instagram i'm not
feeling too well today everyone yeah try
to get some free stuff and brands hey
guys i got a headache yeah i don't know
you guys in for some headache medicine
believe you guys
tagging bear
not a sponsor but you know it could be
um
yeah i mean i'm sorry for the world i'm
sorry for everyone but certainly for his
uh
as a friend of his you know i'm really
sorry man
that one thing it taught me man it was
like
you you there are no excuses if you have
you know a few things right if you feel
like doing something just do it like and
anyone who knows me
i'm not the most adventurous person in
the world like i'll watch you be
adventurous because that's exciting
yeah well i don't know i started i
started to see more adventurous side
come out um
on instagram when you were training for
or when you were doing blood show oh
yeah
uh you started getting really
max and jake and i were laughing about
this you started getting really jacked i
did i did and what was that experience
like you shot in south africa
right yeah south cape town
cape town london yeah everywhere how did
you get so ripped i remember thinking
like oh he's this might be
this might be something we can't talk
about juice no i was on the video no
no because you know over the years i've
always maintained uh the mindset that
i'm going to get in shape one day you
know
i always i always said it i even though
negro like you can ask jake and max i
would there will be times where i would
drop like 15 pounds
while filming and be working out quite
often and then you get to work and then
you're kind of put in check by max
greenfield was like it's six we have a 6
30 a.m call time and i've already done a
two-hour workout you know and i'm like
yeah that's right he was doing that
every day
that's training oh okay never mind sorry
i just i kind of i went to as it's like
all or nothing yeah i guess it'll be
nothing there's nothing for me so i
remember getting the film booking the
movie and knowing that my character
wasn't necessarily a superhero
but i gave myself i told myself like
look this is when i say legit the
director had nothing to do with this the
script did not call for it
but i told myself that it did i was like
oh yeah i'm in a superhero franchise now
here's what i'm gonna do i would do that
this is what a great excuse yeah and so
i bet they got your trainer and stuff no
i did oh
i did it myself
they were like oh really got to the
point where when we started doing recent
time that we shot the original um you
know principal photography that up until
the there's about almost a year gap
maybe about six to the re-shoot the
reshoots right almost uh-huh and we had
i'm talking like a whole new set of
shoots like to the point i shot more in
the resources than i did in the original
oh my god you know you know because my
character was hard never a great sign
well it wasn't what it was my character
well here's what it was it was a good
sign for me
because my character
was only in a few scenes in the second
half of the movie he was meant to be a
part of the this trio that goes on as
character defense character my character
however
you know there are certain parts of the
movie that lacked levity
so they were like okay let's write more
and bring him back in to fill in these
gaps of just pure action because it was
just non-stop action for a long time you
know okay we need somebody to break up
the monotony of the action so they
rewrote scenes and have me come in and
just do goofy bits and for me i remember
coming back in funny really jacked guy
you know what's crazy yeah i was i had
belly came out to here you know like
before and then when i came back the
director was like
what
well they i wish they had written that
in like what a transformation people
would have thought like you went through
this it was like a real de niro
thing
but they did and i was so pissed i was
like okay maybe in this scene i'll have
a shirt on what you think dave wilson he
was like everybody i don't know if
that's the thing i don't know if you
should be you're too jacked you know i
don't know
i was like all right cool all right it
sucks because i just went and got
shredded for nothing thanks dude
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
was there a point where you decided i
want to be an actor or was it a gradual
thing that you or something that you
just kind of like stumbled on how did
that happen before we get to that i do
want everybody to know out there that um
sex symbol has been a word used to
describe me after i after my uh
transformation that is true i was
getting to that too that was my second
thing yeah so i just is that
uncomfortable for you
to no uh be known as that one thing do
you like to be painted with other
brushes no no you can paint me with that
brush all day
okay let me tell you something y'all
need a lot of pain
yeah
um
i also want to hear some impressions
because you're
you're brilliant at impressions but
um
yeah uh what okay how about this how
would we combine them at what point did
you know you wanted to be an actor oh we
can't do bill cosby [ __ ] can you not do
bill cosby you do such a good cause are
you not allowed to do that uh no i don't
he just mind yeah
bill cosby mine
uh no i think you know what's crazy is
that
i do impressions if i never really do
them meaning i just goof around and
never get the opportunity i think one
movie game night they had asked me to do
denzel impression
and it was
and it's such a the denzel impression is
so time of day kind of thing
like what do you mean because you do it
great i've heard it it's incredible well
because his voice is so smooth but deep
and has this kind of air to it that when
i first wake up in the morning
that's what my voice is
is at it's most denzel you understand
what i'm telling you
and so
so a lot of times i can't
like um
like if i was to sit here and tell you
uh uh justin huh and thanks for having
me on your podcast
and it means a lot yeah because not a
lot of people put me in their podcast
sucker you understand what i'm telling
you
yeah
so
that's great that's great but tell me
you have you ever done a denzel off with
jay pharaoh
no but we're supposed to because he is
like he is like the gift to impressions
he's incredible but like i gotta say
that is
your mannerisms i i
there's something so subtly good about
that one too not to say that fair chase
isn't but i would but god i would love
to there's a there's a youtube video
that my buddy melvin greg made i forget
what it's called but it's denzel
impressions and um and there's four
characters playing poker
and they're all denzel's from different
movies there's flight decks okay yeah
there's there's john q denzel
there's a there's flight denzel
he's like i was drunk
i'm drunk right now
yeah you know there's a there's the
american gangster denzel
uh and then a training day denzel and
they're all
you know arguing over you know whose
money whose money it belongs to
and amazing and it was such a fun thing
for me to do because
you know these are all my friends and
we're just goofing around and my buddies
like everybody has this little studio
space and
and we would he just asked me to come by
and do it i did it and before you know
it it like turned into this thing where
like jamie foxx has mentioned it to hey
man i saw your denzel video man and i'm
like oh yeah you're jimmy fox oh my god
like that's good yeah just that one line
you said
hey man
hey man look hey hey look
that's that's fine
do you need do you need like uh i
noticed with like with jamie you go hey
man do you need certain yeah um you need
certain lots
like it's like a it's like a
what you would call it but it's like a
warm-up word yeah what is that it's like
um
it's it's a focal point it's like
something that you need to it's an ism
that they'd have it's an ism that they
have that people identify with
immediately so no matter what you do
like with denzel if you go back to uh
huh
you know if you say one of those yeah
you understand what i'm telling you yeah
like people with with um
with morgan with uh christopher walken
it's crying crazy the word crazy crazy
is a good centering word or like
with morgan freeman it's it's the name
uh
and andy dufry and andy just saying andy
my voice is i like that time of the day
impression yeah
and and it was my friend friend friend
the
that's one impression i wish i could do
there's this guy oh who is that guy
who's that white guy who does it and you
don't know the difference i forget his
yes
i forget his name it's crazy oh my god
he's narrated films as morgan freeman
before it is yes
even morgan freeman's like that's pretty
good yeah
i had no idea that
[Laughter]
uh that's funny um okay and also i wanna
know um
i really wanna know uh when you had
dinner with john mayer yes because i've
been i've i swear to god lemon i've been
in similar situations with jeffrey ross
and john mayer and it's like john's
workshop and some materials so like
great i want to hear some guitar
i can't wait and it's like nope he
is doing
comedy and it's like wow yeah and by the
way i went to high school with john i
really liked john uh he hopefully will
be on the show uh but but i remember
being like
uh you're i mean yeah like some it's
funny this stuff's funny but you're so
good at guitar
you can't you just be happy
but here's what i will say
i saw him at a party once
with chappelle and he was playing the
guitar and chappelle was
talking and just talking to the crowd
and
it was one of the coolest things i've
ever seen in my life yeah i remember he
was doing that yeah and i was like
yo that would be such a dynamic duo of
like oh yeah if he if like you know if
because to be to be honest him working
on it for a while i i genuinely think if
you're if once you're familiar with the
stage
if you have any comedic inkling in your
body you could get there
the comfortability of being on stage is
the issue for a lot of people totally
and he can just command a crowd of 30 40
50 000 people i'm sure he's played for
bigger crowds you know what i mean right
that's a good point yeah it's getting
out of your own way it's having the
confidence to kind of stand up and talk
to people okay these are lightning round
quick questions yes what is your most
commonly used emoji
these hands
oh uh they're you're putting the thumbs
together i always thought like that was
like a praise like an all like a praise
you know what's cool
i think it is but for me
there are probably a ton of confused
people out there
who get this response from me but for me
it's one of those i guys see jay-z throw
up the rock side like yo like yeah like
that's dope that's the reason why i do
i've seen it used that way too lamar and
i think you can use it yeah that's why i
do it because sometimes i know how to
respond to fans or and i don't want to
necessarily write a long monologue
because then we'll never stop writing
back and forth
and
and
it's true so i'll just go like yeah i
know hey i see you and i think that's a
dope remark you just made or that's a
nice comment you made oh okay so that's
cool you know i'm acknowledging like yo
this we had this connection like and
i'll continue to talk it's not that i
won't it's just that that's just the
automatic go to when i'm like not trying
to
have a full coverage oh i'm in the
middle of something and i can't respond
oh i think that that's that conveys like
respect yeah like thank you and yeah so
that's that's very multi-functional
i find myself doing a lot of this kind
of like guy the smile but kind of
looking down a little like yeah i'm
bowing a little bit there's a little
humility and like i like what you've
said you know who are you talking to the
world leaders
what i'm texting with kofi and on yes
um or
or desmond tutu um
yeah what else do i do i'll do a lot of
um you know i've been doing the kissy
i've been doing like heart kiss a lot
yeah unfortunately not with romantic
partners just like with like friends and
sister just a lot
i found myself doing that a lot because
especially a lot of these people i'm
texting like i do it with you because
like i wanna send love to you i want to
like kiss you i want to like because i
have it in so long yes
i haven't kissed the person like
yeah yeah
if you could be a professional athlete
uh what sport would you play basketball
easily basketball oh my gosh absolutely
unless bowling would pay out like nba
players get paid
are you a good bowler i'm a decent
bowler i i could become a professional
bowler before i become a professional
basketball player huh wow because
bowling i could
i'm not getting beat up there's not a
lot of people taller than me jumping
over me
there's no one nearly as athletic as you
yeah you would be in a category to
yourself is this something i just have
to work out i can work at basketball all
day long but then if i get on the court
with freaking lebron james then it's
like all right man
like that there's nothing i can do about
this
you must have been a big bulls fan
absolutely grown up absolutely yeah i
mean i'm right now i'm a lebron james
guy like i think lebron is the greatest
player of all time but yeah i'm a bulls
guy if you have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be one
snack food for the rest of my life would
be
um snickers
is that ah it would either be it would
either be the almond snickers
or uh cool ranch doritos
oh man i love both of those that's great
those are my two yeah
i want to say oh you know very great
call um
what's your favorite movie of all time
the matrix
the
funny uh
it's so funny because the matrix we were
talking about that today because
i forget why it came up it came up um
god i was listening to sports radio
and but it was on my mind because of
your show there's a reference to it yeah
very like
it's such an appropriate reference to it
on your show right do i take the red
pill or the blue pill you know yes um
yeah your when your character is is
waking up there's that moment where
you're it's so good everyone i want you
to watch it but there's that moment
where you can you can choose basically
to continue to live in this
reality where everything's fine and
you're this very safe cartoonist or you
know um
you you you open your eyes and you
unplug it's great exactly so that's the
that's the
that's the cool part of the show is what
you know especially for people out there
watching it's like
you we can all take that bread pill or
that blue pill you know the options are
in front of us so you know if you had to
live somewhere else where would it be
oh
man
if i could
right now i live in los angeles
i love miami i just i just love
everything about miami but
you know
is it is it is it a cop-out to say i
live in chicago because that's where i'm
from
no that's great you know i like i like
keeping things local you got family you
know family there yeah you still have a
family there but yeah most of my
family's there it's just me and my
brother uh out in um
in l.a
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met who would it be
jesus
because i want to know all about it i
want to know what's real what's not real
what they say about you you know can you
really what are your
yeah and how what do you think of it are
you like freaked out that all of this
has happened in your name uh yeah
exactly you know i would love to want to
know his perspective on things maybe
martin luther king jr just because
i felt like there was more to
what he was doing that we never got a
chance to understand or know or
you know maybe like it's that matrix
thing what is behind the curtain what
are we missing what aren't we getting
man this is tough
this is like there's so many people that
i would want i know it's not a great
lightning run question
no it's like that's a lightning round oh
my god uh we can come back to it but
those are so far
just to mix it up you know i know i
would probably say zoe kravitz
i just i just oh i just i just find her
fascinating
just why you just really do
why not zoey'd be like wow she can't she
definitely comes to the door yeah she
goes you know that you know she's
accepting that information okay it's me
jesus and mlk what's up
yeah
and who
lamore morris
okay exactly yeah
the uh the guy that everybody wants to
69.
okay
i've heard of him his name raises bells
in these streets
he's the 69 guy
who this hopefully be easier who's your
favorite muppet um kermit
i'd probably say kermit just because his
voice and i like that it's such an easy
voice to do that i like it yeah
yeah yeah you do any you do yeah well i
mean every i think everyone can do just
kermit the frog here just turn the voice
in it's really just the thing with your
voice so funny uh
who was i just having do that did the
same exact thing had that reaction
kermit and well because it's easy to do
um
you know i go back to my other answer i
would probably put um and now this is a
more selfish read on things
i would go
jesus eddie murphy
and meryl streep and here's why
it's because jesus because then i don't
need to know what mlk's got going on
because jesus will kind of give me the
the real and the scoop you know right
they got to know each other they have to
be homies you know
so it's true murphy because i think he's
the goat i think he's just and i've
never met him so i'm interested well
that's another not just tee you up but
like that's another brilliant impression
you do
that's like you know what i don't
remember i
oh you did such a good eddie murphy and
didn't they write it into the new girl
they did once and i and i never really
officially did an eddie murphy
impression just because so many people
did it that i would take my shot at it
yeah it's a lot of times people people
understand you're gonna have dinner with
somebody like me
can't i don't know if i could that is so
good you just did it
[Laughter]
uh
and then meryl streep i think she's the
greatest actor of all time so
she's so good that i
like i'll see her in things and i never
see a false moment and i'm like how does
she look so natural playing
this character and now that character
comedy drama funny like it's like man i
know
i was thinking her about her the other
day in the context of like feeling good
about
being an actor and feeling good about
looking forward to acting again i was
thinking about it and um and like one of
the reasons i love it is like i feel
myself getting better i feel like
but but i i know i will never be able to
do what she does right there's just like
she's one of those people that like
raises the bar has raised it so high
that like meryl streep is somebody i can
i just couldn't do you just couldn't do
it and i get that same feeling from you
know obviously from her but you know
like a denzel you know i watch him in
all his movies and he's he's so in
control
i was watching flight right before i got
on uh with you
and even in the moments where the plane
is going down he's still just
okay grab the leather
move it yeah yeah
like man if my plane was going to crash
i'd want him to be the guy that's
sitting next to me
totally totally in control well you have
uh moments
when you're having your like
quote-unquote breakdown you
what's so great about that in the pilot
of woke is that you are so in control of
being out of control if that makes any
sense yeah it's almost like people
should have stayed there i mean people
in the show leave the room and they're
like what the [ __ ] happening but like
it's a real dynamic like i've come to
jesus oh yeah come to your dinner friend
moment oh yeah thank you man thank you
if you had to be one age for the rest of
your life what would you pick physically
physically 25 yes oh god do i miss yeah
i didn't take advantage of me being 25
when i like me there i know
i had some fun but not yeah yeah i think
you were i think you had a reputation
for having some fun
you were quite the ladies man there
25 was um
yeah i guess i did have some fun uh
if if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you be
oof uh i want to say a lion uh because
you know i got a chance to go to a
safari and watch how the lions like are
respected
however
they it's so hot out there and they just
look lazy as [ __ ] so i'm like oh yeah
would i want to be a lion maybe a spider
monkey i like i feel like they jump and
they do all this crazy stuff and they
fly around they always look like they're
having fun jumping around so i don't
know one of those to probably pick the
lion just because
i'd be the boss and i get to just
eat one time a day and just chill and
rest and you could hang out without the
spider-man yeah you can feel really good
i need a nice line probably hard to
perform yeah exactly
yeah
uh would you rather be called
unattractive or unfunny unattractive
unattractive because i know women that
especially what we do you know what i
mean like you know scientists you know
have their thing right a lot of tech
tech bros and tech nerds and stuff like
they have their thing they have a skill
set which people find attractive so
no matter what you look like as long as
you're bringing something to the table
that's attractive i agree there's a lot
of dumb good looking people out there
you know who can't care
well not in l.a
um
which which golden girl do you most
identify with dorothy blanche rose or
sophia i want to say blanche because
she's a little freaky
isn't that the best she definitely is
she's not freaking funny
yeah
we always
tiptoe around what blanche is we always
my brother and i never know how to
exactly describe her and i'm the the one
we usually use is um she's a good time
charlie yeah yeah
because there's like an innocence to
that term that like
but she's she is
[Laughter]
as
well yes yes yeah god bless her
i i that's something to aspire to um
what uh which do you prefer dogs or cats
dogs dogs i would work with a cat for a
while but it was not
all that it
that's right like oh my god that was
allergic to cats the cat would scratch
me randomly
and i was like you can't train a cat you
just have to give it you have to tell
the cat where to look by clicking and
hope for the best give food and it'll
look and then walk off and you go oh we
got it
so
you know so yeah a dog at least so if
ever
if ever you were a dog guy before that
ferguson your experience working
ferguson solidifies absolutely
absolutely cats are too selfish too like
they'll just come get food and then
peace out and you're like all right man
like
where's our friendship here
you know beetles are the rolling stones
beetles uh you know do you have a
favorite song
eleanor rigby i love eleanor rigby
um i love that song and then
i want to what's it called lovely people
what's that song is it illinois look at
all the logos yeah yeah
look at all these lonely people
i don't really know i just like your
kestrel yeah it's just such a cool song
to me but maybe
i think this is just a john lennon song
imagine i really like that song but you
know i i equate that with the beatles um
yeah but he was a beautiful yeah i did a
movie called yesterday
um oh dude you're so good at it i
[ __ ]
love that
i
i and i saw it on a plane and it
destroyed me i saw it my i didn't know
you were in it a friend of mine was like
uh or urged me to see it and i was like
i don't know i had such such little like
i had no hopes going on i was really not
looking it blew me away i loved that
that movie like even if i weren't in it
it's one of those cool concepts that i
just like and i love the music and you
know and and it all just made it all
just worked for me when i when i read it
oh man but i see i think the reason i
was so resistant to it i the beatles to
me are so sacred that i was like it felt
gimmicky and they're i don't know i'm
embarrassed saying this now because it
really um it was one of my favorite
movies that year if not my favorite and
you were such a welcome surprise like in
a sea of like great surprises you um
lamorn plays a a uh
kind of like a soulless executive yeah
yeah it was also a great role for you
i've never seen you do a rolex yeah and
meet me either i hadn't you know so that
was kind of funny yeah uh uh richard
curtis um danny boyle danny boyle
director richard curtis wrote it and i
mean let me tell you who was like
incredible i i'm like really embarrassed
that i was so i don't know why
richard curtis and danny boyle
you know what's interesting about
working with you know oscar-winning
director in oscar you know these guys
are these guys are like legends you know
what i mean yeah the craziest thing is
that it's not what you think i'm i was
thinking like i'd go i'd go there and
they'd be so like hard on me and like
really intense they were so chilly they
were playful very pleasant oh no kidding
improvise have fun you know danny's like
danny's like i'm in control of the shot
you're the actor
you know you're in control of your
character so
have fun man and then i'll i'll capture
it you know
uh no man i i'm such a fan of yours and
and i'm so glad we got to do this this
is uh i really appreciate it dude man
you know for those who don't know
i'm just gonna i've said this to you
before i'm not sure if i've said it
publicly i think i said it went to like
instagram or something like that
you are legit one of my favorite actors
one of my favorite performers of all
time and i'm not saying this because
you're here we work together
when i heard you were gonna be on on new
girl
i was so weirded out because i was like
am i now in this world where
justin long's about to come to set and
this is so strange to me
you were so humble and chill and like
what you did on set
until this day has formed the way i
perform
because i was so timid
to
rub anybody the wrong way i didn't want
to try things i wasn't very daring and
then the stuff that you would do
i just remember one scene in particular
that
actually got me in trouble later on
when you weren't there and i'll tell you
and i'll explain why
okay my character's name is winston and
you like to you
like to do this bit where you never said
my name right
i was like
i don't know why to this day it makes me
laugh i don't know why it's so good
in one take
that's insane
that's so dumb unusable and i remember
the director going hey justin just say
his name the right way and then like
make a quicker and quicker exit and then
you were like
okay you're like oh hey hey schmidt hey
winston's and then you sit with an ass
like to this day i get tears thinking
about it and i remember trying i
remember another director
years later
wanted me to exit a scene quicker and i
was doing a bit and they're like hey
mark you just go a little faster so i
took the note and went a little faster
and he was like i hate to do this can
you go a little bit faster so i thought
i found myself going faster and then he
goes
we're gonna do a more take blah blah
blah whatever hey lemon look man i don't
wanna be that dude man i'm so sorry but
like
like when you get up and just just get
up and just go and i was like all right
and i in my mind immediately i'm about
to pull it justin
and so
on our couch
we had that leather brown couch and i
had to get up so what i said i was going
to do i was going to
the camera was right here and i and i
had it all figured out like the table
was right here it was pointing right in
front of him camera's pointing right at
him i was going to jump
and try to leap over
the camera i was going to do it that's
amazing i was going to do a whole thing
but i was going to use the i was going
to use momentum from pushing myself off
the couch the problem is the cushions
were so old that there was like a dead
spot in the cushion too much give yeah i
pushed down on the couch and dislocated
my thumb
and you can hear it on camera i wish i
had that video if anyone's listening to
this if you're in person
whoever said that i think i forget who
it was who sent me the video
i went i pushed down and all you hear is
this
oh my god lamorne that's insane i love
you for having that instinct uh and i
love you
for saying what you just said but i uh
i don't know i like working stuff out
before but i i i have that instinct that
yeah which is like all right i'm gonna
[ __ ] go you have to you have to and
then i said i found that a little bit
with damon as well damon once did a
cartwheel in the middle of a scene for
no reason
he once
walked he once walked in in the scene
with his pants down like bare ass out
like new girls like just walk through
you on a thanksgiving episode once
ran out of a room and jumped over a
couch and fell
quote unquote fell so that we all
stopped wait did he fall for real
that's right i heard that i heard um one
of the camera guys made it ooh like a
noise
i remember
i remember being behind the couch
thinking yeah it's a great feeling when
you um
when you get people to stop
they think you're hurt like is he hurt
for real
oh man i that's so nice to say i i just
really admire you and i i i'm so proud
of you in the show this show is [ __ ]
great man um i appreciate that i'm
excited for people yeah i'm excited for
you i'm excited to see what it you know
does to you in in your career so well
thank you man thank you thank you thank
you
[Music]
so
that happened oh uh i was gonna do his
um
that that
well what's this great impression that
he she has a few great great but i
didn't know he was that good at
impressions that's right you never yeah
he doesn't really do he does a version a
little bit of um jamie foxx in some in
some episode they laugh
i can't do it that's more eddie murphy
though eddie murphy i'm sorry i'm sorry
i don't know well they're both really
talented people okay
but you know i noticed his natural laugh
is a little bit like that too it is
right yeah
i think he just i remember him telling
me that he watched him so much as a kid
that well similar to how i was with
michael j fox yeah like uh i wouldn't
say my laugh is like his but i'd certain
mannerisms certain words are definitely
i can't even picture what michael j
fox's laugh sounds like he's not a big
laughter no he's not lamorne is just
speaking michael j fox uh he really
likes you that was really nice what he
said about you that was really that was
like moving yeah it was really nice
he's so cool he doesn't he doesn't
strike me as like a real like gushy i
tend to be very as listeners know um
what would you say effusive
that's about how much i like certain
things you are effusive and he yeah he
that surprised me at the end because he
doesn't i don't know him but it he
doesn't strike me as that kind of person
no no which which means that it's more
authentic yeah not that you're not
authentic
no i know but but when somebody like me
is a more effusive person says something
like that uh yeah it doesn't carry as
much weight i don't think as as when
somebody who you know you're not used to
hearing speak that way right speaks that
way about you and it's somebody like
that i really admire somebody especially
after i've always liked lamorne a lot i
thought he was such an underrated
component of new girl uh you guys talked
about chadwick boseman and i hadn't
heard
anyone who actually knew him you know
you've seen so many of these tributes on
instagram lately and it's you know black
panther kids looked up to him black
panther all this and and others i've
read other celebrities have been posting
about it but to hear from someone
directly who knew him really humanized
that guy in a way that
um made it that much more tragic hearing
about it
and and about his strength both his
strength physical strength but mental
strength and his focus and his intensity
as uh
as an actor and a writer and like how
much he cared about his craft and it you
know it's amazing a really
special human being yeah and a really
like evolved human being like uh he
seemed so present and
yeah like you said strong life's not
fair nice not fair you talk about john
mayer and how he
has a real passion for comedy and
and comedians he's friends with jeff
ross and bob saget and he really values
comedy and and his and his uh place in
the comedic sphere and i think he's been
trying to get more in it for years and i
agree with you for years i've always
thought
he's
one of the greatest guitar players who's
ever lived
why can't he just do that
and i've thought that way up until
hearing you guys talk about him and i
for the first time i realized i don't
own him right who like who am i to tell
that guy he enjoys what he can do he
enjoys it yeah you can't i know i feel
the same way now i know you can't why
dictate what that you don't have to
think that john mayer has every right to
be a comedian
i love how you talked about um you know
we've always been so delicate about
talking about blanche in the culture
yeah i know he's like is that the [ __ ]
and you're like yeah we tried that yeah
leaves words like that and he's like oh
no she's a hoe
i know i know i
i i i'm not saying that by the way no
i'm just quoting i'm quoting him yeah
yeah
no lamorne can get away with that why
i think he's cooler for one thing he
says in a way that it's clearly not yes
it's weird it's like it does that word
the way he uses it doesn't have any
bite or or um it's casual it's casual i
can't say that word casually it's the
way michael jordan called scott burrell
remember when he called scott barela ho
yeah
i'm quoting michael jordan by the way i
wouldn't use that word it's certainly
not on scott parrell
i'd be like yeah scott paparello is an
nba player for those who don't know him
so any nba player all right let's read a
letter all right cool
you like how i just
got right into that yeah i like it
uh oh wow this is from eb davis i
you know i used to love eb white yeah
and never author great author of uh
charlotte webb and little but i've never
seen another eb this is eb
um subject came for the laughs stayed
for the would you rathers ah
okay
hey nerds
nerds yeah we're nerds yeah well we are
if the shoe fits
yeah
uh interesting uh so far we can play the
game do you think
not that you know gender is i know a
construct but do you think this is a
woman or a man um hey nerds from eb
that's hilarious very very good question
thank you i i have a first guess but i'm
gonna keep it to myself so oh really uh
on the count of three one two three man
oh wow
okay i think it's a woman i should have
said woman not girl sorry it could be a
girl yeah that's true
that's true it could be a little tiny
shorty yeah a little shorter fully
shorter as hilarious and charming as it
is to hear you interview someone by the
way by the way sorry it's interrupt yeah
shorties are um for those who don't know
oh it's not just our like vain we didn't
name people who listen to the show it's
a it's a specific
group on facebook
called uh life is short with justin long
official shout out to the show shorties
it's like the fan club on on facebook
yeah that's kind of cool so we didn't
create it yeah but so if you guys want
to go be a shortie go on
facebook if you're not on facebook yeah
you're on you're i'm a shorty yeah yeah
dr kessler's a shorty dr dave dr dave uh
sometimes maggie maggie she's a shorty
yeah she's a short and she'll read
maggie reed will read some of the um
comments and dr dave is quite active on
it yes which is cool uh we gotta get him
back okay
back to eb as hilarious and charming as
it is to hear you interview someone you
seem to really click with as sadistic as
this sounds i think i enjoy hearing you
try to navigate your way through the
more challenging interviews even more
it's interesting
you try to navigate you test out some
potential shared interests sprinkle in
some humor and it cracks me up whether
the attempts are successful or not i'll
tell ya i laughed harder than i have in
a long time while listening to y'all's
assessment of the very spicy interview
with nathan lane that's funny i agree
with eb it's funny to see you yeah it's
funny to see you uh like make a joke
with someone like nathan lane and he
just does not register it and it just
like sits out there or even yeah
or even worse he registers it and is
like uh that he's i'm not even gonna
touch that i'm not even gonna like
i love it i'll eat that all day
as someone whose work directly involves
elections
i wanted to tell you that i greatly
appreciate the laughter you two provide
especially right now these times are
weird and scary and there's still so
much work to be done in this world but
please rest assured that elections
elections workers and officials are
working harder than ever to ensure that
citizens can safely vote in accurate
fair open and secure elections that is
that's good news so such good news yeah
we want a fair election yes eb thank you
for that for doing that
anyways i wanted to share one of my
favorite ever would you rathers created
by my devilish friend carrie
do you have a different opinion now
whether
what her what their gender is
um
i wanted to show i'm leading more woman
now
i wanted to share one of my favorite
ever would you rather is created by my
devilish friend carrie
it's also the way i'm reading it maybe
for context she also sat me down and
forced me to watch tusk oh my god don't
do that dear friend
is that a good friend
uh i usually relish in people's facial
reactions to this one but since i can't
see you two oh well here we go okay
i'm excited
would you rather
have an extra set of arms coming out of
the side of your torso that are skinny
hairy and have a mind of their own
eg they swing clap and touch people's
faces when you're speaking with them
that's funny
or
have an extra partially developed head
coming out of your neck that has one
tooth drools constantly droops over to
the side and rarely speaks but when it
does it's obnoxious and demanding and
sounds eerily like gilbert godfrey oh it
sounds like gilbert godfrey to me this
is pretty easy okay so it rarely speaks
but every every once in a while it'll be
like hey you're gonna finish that
is that a good it's okay he he's a
little bit i'm i'm pushing it too hard
yeah it's okay yeah i'm trying to
remember what he sounds like is he gonna
like
how do you how would you do it you want
to attempt it no okay
okay it's kind of like this it's a
little bit more just annoyed
yeah i mean i like this it's not quite
that high or neat it's a little bit like
this
[Music]
oh god sorry listeners yeah um
this one's easy for me is that the end
of the hypothetical yeah yeah easy i
would say if that
for me it's if the head didn't talk
because you could put your arms in you
know keep him if the head didn't talk
then it's then i'd have to think about
it uh even if it didn't talk i'd still
pick me too but the fact that the head
can talk it's like oh and you never know
what it's going to say exactly what if
it says you're did you know exactly and
if it's okay it rarely talks but when do
i how do i know when it's going to say
something inappropriate
whereas if you have
a hands that do whatever they want all
you have to do is stay away from it by
the way that was my hypothetical
vestigio i know i know all you if you
had um feral hands all you had to all
you have to do yeah well keep them away
well first of all you strap them down
first of all you only wear ponchos
number one number two okay you just
that'd be annoying of course
you know it's more annoying having a
little head coming out of your neck yeah
i wonder how little it is though because
if it's little enough you could maybe
cover that thing up with like a scarf
yes an ascot you just wear like
pretentious theater scarves you wouldn't
want to do that i'd rather wear a um a
poncho no you wouldn't have a parka a
big parka and have two arms that may by
the way those arms might break out of
that poncho and start that's true but
see i already have skinny little arms
that
the thought of having one more setup
they would have a mind of their own
that's true but i would just make sure
i'd capture arm's length from everybody
because everybody everybody what if you
had to hug someone like you wanna i
would i would prepare them verbally for
what might you might get goosed you
might get goosed uh grandma yeah okay
i've got these two hands that that i
can't control
it's easier to explain that i've got a
little head and it's gilbert godfrey
head i wouldn't want that head yeah
i would say no offense to governor
godfrey i wouldn't want the head if it
was like you know uh denzel washington
or somebody cool and like with a cool
voice that's an interesting question
maybe would you rather have feral arm
the arm one yeah or
denzel washington little head on the
side of your head which is cool who's
cool who says he's like that's who
washington i would probably want to i'd
want the tents i washington but but
here's the problem with that it would be
cool in a way it would upstage you
completely yeah then your main head
would look so much more pathetic and
growing like unattractive of course in
every way
it would be better denzel washed his
head is better than my head in every
sense but maybe not but see she
describes it as uh it's got one tooth
drools constantly troops over the side
and rarely speaks so if it was a little
underdeveloped like drooling hat you
know if it was that that's why i
wouldn't want it yeah yeah but a denzel
washington head that'd be tough
or a tom brady head yeah who was just
talking about tom brady oh somebody on
instagram
because dax had tom brady on his show
and i was like oh man even though i'm a
chest i said something on his instagram
and somebody was like uh i just assumed
you guys were patriots fans the way you
carry on about
brady no we just admire his beauty
and now we're buccaneers fans you would
think yeah you'd think by the way he
looks great in that uniform sure does
didn't play a great game but who cares
look at that face and when he gets
because he got angry because he was not
doing well it's you know he's so
attractive
um that was a great that was a great uh
hypothetical yeah it was fun to imagine
oh okay back to eb's letter that's it
smell ya later eb
oh we don't get any uh clarification on
the gender no but you know what maybe
that's good maybe like who who cares
smell you later why
i bet once you know i was starting out
now i think it's a woman
yeah i think i i think i think but i
could really could go either way
or maybe
um eb does not identify yeah with either
eb maybe uh non-binary yeah and that's
that's okay too that's really cool i i i
think that's interesting um
but i don't know why for some reason
like that is still
something i think about well that's the
way you i guess describe somebody
because i want to know about i want to
know about eb i want to picture picture
them right
yeah where they're from because i want
to
it helps you know anyway your gender and
outstanding thank you for the letter
that was fantastic eb or maybe you
pronounce it ebb if you guys want to
write in our email addresses life is
short our ebail our email address is
life is short at wondery.com
and thank you to the uh hilarious and
very kind yeah
lamar and morris good guy really good
guy and now we've had three out of your
four new girl cast mates we gotta get
zoe zoey we texted about it hold out oh
and hannah simone would be good hannah
would be great yeah and other people on
that show god rob reiner who played um
somebody's dad would be awesome uh
that show is really the gift that keeps
on giving because i i did not not do
many episodes that and uh really loved
those people getting to work anyway uh i
can't thank lamorn enough for doing that
being so open and uh please watch his
truly like that show is i think i think
it's gonna
i this sounds so lame but like i think
he's it's gonna win awards well who
cares about awards i know but it's just
but you should see it cause it's really
good it's really good important i think
uh so thanks to l'moren and um thanks to
eb
and uh thanks to everyone listening we
love doing the show it's been fun and
we'll talk to you it sounds like it's
over it sounds like the show is ending
it'd be a terrible way to end yeah so
casual um thanks for listening this
weekend we will talk to you next week
how about that yeah good okay and stay
tuned for a voice memo
life could be a dream
life
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by you
christian long and megan monaco senior
producer is michelle you want to try
that one again senior producer is
michelle lance audio engineer is sergio
enriquez executive producers are
marshall louie and ernon last name lopez
for wandery
stay safe
[Music]
he like pointed out that no one was
answering this yeah then he didn't
answer it
wait what's his name tom steyer yeah i
can't believe that
wait so if he looks like would you say
if fred freddy krueger hadn't been
burned became a businessman
fred krug fred hi fred kruger yeah uh
joe fred kruger uh fred i want you to
meet jim stapleton
fred krueger over here is heading up our
east coast division
[Laughter]
yeah yeah he really does look like uh
bobby england he's like yeah i was a
school janitor for some time but um
going back to school getting my degree
getting my mba
and running for local office
you